نركز على كرة القدم ، نحن
منظمة لكرة القدم تهتم فعليًا
بالعمال الذين
[الموسيقى]
وننظر في قضية
الهجرة هذه ووضع مئات
الآلاف من النساء والرجال من
البلدان النامية الذين يرغبون في
تقديم خدماتهم في الخارج في  من أجل
المساعدة ومنح مستقبل لعائلاتهم ،
حسنًا ، تقدم قطر
لهم أوروبا
الأجنبية ،
فنحن نغلق حدودنا ولا
نسمح عمليًا لأي عامل من هذه
البلدان
ممن لديهم
دخل منخفض للغاية بالعمل بشكل قانوني
في بلداننا  لأننا نعلم جميعًا أن
هناك العديد من العمال غير الشرعيين
في بلداننا الأوروبية
[موسيقى
] ، يجب أن نفهم الطفل
أننا مختلفون وكذلك
لدينا معتقدات مختلفة لعمل التاريخ المختلف الذي
نأتي إليه من خلفيات مختلفة
ولكننا في نفس العالم
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن ما كنا نفعله نحن الأوروبيين
في آخر 3000 سنة حول
العالم يجب أن نعتذر عن
3000 سنة قادمة قبل  التفتت لإعطاء دروس أخلاقية
[تصفيق].